[Musik]
wie's unbekannten amerika erpressen für
abend ihre knochen flug aufwind
[Musik]
er wurde
spricht sich der name so aus südamerika
kommen sie zu meinem wagen
[Musik]
was denkst du
wir waren über 100 und hier ist 75
mein name ist arthur honegger acht jahre
lang waren die usa mein zuhause als
korrespondent bin ich in dieser zeit
ganz schön rumgekommen 47 von 50
bundesstaaten habe ich besucht und auch
heute noch beschäftigt mich dieses große
verrückte land praktisch nonstop bei
meiner fernseharbeit in dieser serie
will ich nun ein unbekanntes amerika
entdecken
abseits der großen politik neue staaten
neue menschen neue erfahrungen
[Musik]
aber kirk i die größte stadt in mexiko
und trotzdem so ein ort an den es einen
kaum je verschlägt
jetzt bin ich hier
unsere reise beginnt am flughafen aber
eigentlich wollen wir diesen stadler auf
der straße erfahren im wahrsten sinn des
wortes mexiko
[Musik]
ein langweiliger mietwagen kommt da
nicht in frage klar wir brauchen ein
auto mit charakter
ja aber wwe ist eilig soll er sein unser
wagen günstig natürlich und so gut
beieinander dass wir ihn am ende der
reise weiterverkaufen können noch den
preis den wir uns wünschen
2000 maximal 3000 dollar und platz für
kameramann sergio regisseur bart und
nicht bloß equipment und gepäck
was habt ihr vor mit dem auto größere
strecken fahren oder etwas rum fahren
nicht auf die berge hoch aber doch auf
den einen oder andern da habe ich was
für euch frische überprüft eingehend ein
2003 fort tagen mit 200.000 km und er
fährt wirklich einsam wie ihr sehen
könnt
naja ein ford taurus ist nicht eben ein
hingucker aber charakter hat er und
platz wir schon noch ein bisschen rum
und dann kommen wir wieder
3500 ist zu teuer also weitersuchen nach
unserem road movie star auf vier rädern
immer bis die leute zu mir kommen meine
tricks mandy hat heute einen alten honda
reinbekommen unfallauto zwar dafür
billig die fahrrad für lässt sich von
außen nicht mehr öffnen
der motor ist gut getriebe irgendwie zu
mir
er sagt niemand will mich da ich kann es
doch nichts wie rein in das ding jetzt
muss es nur noch die probefahrt
überstehen
[Musik]
wie hoch sie ist
wie wahr
[Musik]
er ist ja auch was
die kupplung
das fenster getragen also doch der
taurus schließlich müssen wir uns auf
die kiste verlassen können und
vielleicht lässt sich beim preis ja noch
was machen
habt ihr was gefunden einiges aber ihr
auto ist in der engeren auswahl ja nur
der preis ist uns noch zu hoch 25 wir
taufen den tarifen weil er mich an ein
new yorker taxi erinnert dabei ist new
mexico so ziemlich das gegenteil von new
york wenig menschen viel platz zuerst
fahren wir auf nach santa fe auf 2200
meter über meer
später wollen wir in den süden an die
grenze zu mexiko
die in den letzten jahren zum brennpunkt
der politik geworden ist
rainer fortmann zauberland
so wird new mexico auch genannt und weil
bekanntlich jedem anfang an zauber
innewohnt kommen die menschen genau
darum hier her neu anzufangen sich
selbst zu verwirklichen ihre persönliche
freiheit zu finden
und nichts ist amerikanischer als dass
[Musik]
raum dafür gibt es genug
zwei millionen einwohner verteilen sich
auf eine fläche fast so groß wie
deutschland
[Musik]
[Applaus]
abseits der straße erstrecken sich
einsame täler versteckt hinter felsen
ketten
hier kann man herrlich ungestört sein
ungestört genug um die schrecklichste
waffe der welt zu bauen
anfang der 1990 er jahre erschaffen
einige tausend forscher in diesen bergen
die atombombe
der name der geheimen mission manhattan
project
[Musik]
im juli 1945 beginnt das nukleare
zeitalter
[Musik]
in new mexico wird heute noch an
atomwaffen getüftelt
neugierige journalisten mit kameras sind
da natürlich nicht erwünscht top secret
darum weiter an den ort dessen name
allein schon die western sehnsucht weckt
santa fe mit rund 80.000 einwohnern für
amerikanische verhältnisse eine
kleinstadt
[Musik]
gemütliche urbanität vielleicht sieht
dass die freigeister an die auf der
halben welt nach santa fe kommen auf der
suche nach inspiration zwischen
geschichte und gegenwart zwischen kultur
und kitsch die erdige adobe architektur
der pueblo indianer steht dem erbe aus
der kolonialzeit gegenüber und was einst
europäisch war wurde irgendwann
amerikanisch
doch die erste die indianische
zivilisation ist hier präsenter als
anderenorts in den usa dabei wurde den
menschen auch hier ihr land mit gewalt
interessen
die narben die insbesondere die spanier
den indios zugefügt haben schmerzen bis
heute ich will mit einem der wortführer
der ureinwohner darüber reden
sein name ist le mans kino erlebt im
pueblo auch viel mehr wissen wir nicht
von ihm
unsere kontaktperson gina will uns zu
seinem haus führen
maria jahr haben wir gefunden
ok feuerrings auto
und wer sucht der wird gefunden
in begleitung
was ist los
aber so schnell waren wir nicht erwarten
dass wir uns jetzt gleich sagen und wird
so schnell waren und ich habe meine
papiere im hotel die vom auto
die sollten jetzt haben kann ich bitte
ihren fahrausweis sehen
der ist der kofferraum völlig aus um den
holen wir sind aus der schweiz
wir machen eine reportage waren wir zu
schnell nein aber sie filmten im
wohngebiet wir erhielten anrufe von
bewohnern
sie dachten da wird mit der kamera
jemandem aufgenommen
die wunde einfach durch weil wir ein
bestimmtes haus suchen
es war nicht zu schnell dass ich weiß
mein fehler
nach der freundlichen begegnung mit der
lokalen stammes polizei kommt einer
kleinen odyssee fahren wir doch noch zum
haus von le mans china ich stelle euch
for leaders ist der reporter arthur
honegger erfreut mich freut mich unter
regisseuren hat freut mich willkommen in
unserem haus
wie arbeitet als lehrer und
keramikkünstler und ihr kommt aus der
schweiz
[Musik]
er lebt zusammen mit seiner großmutter
in einem trailer
heute ist auch ließ neffe zu besuch
gleich gibt's mittagessen
ich freue mich seid ihr hier es gibt
wissen suppe gekocht im tontopf und
danke wir haben gehört du machst was
traditionell in der küche unseres volkes
es gibt auch noch das ist eines unserer
traditionellen gericht die familie lebt
nicht in einem traditionellen adobe
lehmhaus aber in einer traditionellen
dorfgemeinschaft und die steht mit
nachdruck ein für ihre kultur
auch der nachwuchs soll wissen was es
bedeutet ein preview indianer zu sein
sie ging darf er schon auf der straße
ist das ja das bin ich
[Musik]
bist du verarbeitet worden
ich nicht eine frau wurde verhaftet und
dagegen hat li protestiert die
sogenannte entrada vor 60 jahren hatten
einige nachkommen der spanischen
kolonialherren damit begonnen in
historischer kriegs montur durch santa
fe zu marschieren um die eroberung der
region zu feiern
[Musik]
der brauch wurde zusehends umstrittene
in den letzten jahren benötigten die
teilnehmer gar polizeischutz in den
straßen der hauptstadt
[Musik]
ich musste aufstehen gegen etwas was ich
für nicht richtig
ich wollte nicht das nächste
generationen das weiter erleben müssen
die die nach uns kommen werden da
kolonialismus gefeiert wurde
es ist eine feier von kolonialer
unterdrückung und das war für mich nicht
mehr akzeptabel
das ging so viele jahre so viel zu viel
und für mich ist es ein sinnbild für all
die probleme die indigenen immer noch
habe ganzen blatt auch heute noch morde
an frauen die nicht aufgedeckt werden
die ölpipelines fehlender wasser shirts
auch in unserer dorfgemeinschaft fanden
wir jetzt zu unserer stimme und wir
sagten dieses feiern von unrecht das
wollen wir nicht mehr sehen und er hatte
erfolg
jetzt nach jahrelangen protesten eine
gute sache dass ihre proteste nun etwas
bewerb genommen ist das hier gehört
werden wir verabschieden uns vom lieh
dem kämpferischen indio
und auf der fahrt zurück ins zentrum von
santa fé denke ich über die freiheit
nach
sie wirkt so unendlich her doch die
eigene freiheit sagt man endet dort wo
die freiheit des anderen beginnt das ist
letztlich der grund dafür dass es die
entrada heute nicht mehr gibt
[Musik]
st
freiheit kann aber auch heißen zwänge
hinter sich zu lassen
die abkehr vom gesellschaftlichen
konventionen
das hat in den 60er und 70er jahren
scharen von hippies nach mexiko geführt
[Musik]
die kinder dieser blumenkinder sind
geblieben groß geworden in kommunen die
landesweit bekannt waren als in der
wahner der gegenkultur
ich frage mich was das mit einem macht
in einer parallelwelt aufzuwachsen
also besuche ich so ein ehemaliges
heimkind nicht wir können kommt rein
milan führt heute eine galerien santa fe
auf dem food oder rechts das bin ich
das tier hat sich noch ganz klein war
sind eine tolle aufnahme
auf einer traditionellen kinder trage
einer indianischen kinder trage
1967 war da kaum zwei monate alt wo wir
eine weile lebten und dann da war ich
zwei zogen wir in die kommunen 8 ich
dachte sie aber es ist wirklich der
eines joggers
sie besuchte er uns für ein paar tage
sie kamen von überall her von der
ostküste
sie suchten eine neue erfahrung in ihrem
leben verbundenheit mit dem land
spiritualität gesundes leben
ja und die indianer waren dabei sehr
wichtig sie haben den hippies gezeigt
wie man hier vom eigenen boden lebt sie
mussten erst lernen wie landwirtschaft
schaffe schaffe häusle baue nicht eben
die fotos hat peters mutter lisa gemacht
der vater hier auf dem traktor war zuvor
manager von bob dylan
[Musik]
das ist meine mutter bei einem kind aus
und hier in der mitte das ist mein vater
der braut auf seine eigenes haus eine
kommune
sie existierte sehr lange erst kürzlich
wurde sie aufgelöst und ich wie du
siehst die sachen wuchsen bei uns
wirklich hervorragend vor allem die
alten indianischen sorgen
so hatte meine mutter mich gerade auf
dem alten holz herd das sieht alles war
ruhig und friedlich aus bist du gern so
aufgewachsen ist toll ist wenn du so
aufwächst du entwickelst ein eigenes
vorstellungsvermögen
du kannst dich selber unterhalten ich
verbrachte den tieren einen eigenen
abend und in der nacht konntest du die
milchstraße sehen das ganze universum in
dem aufzuwachsen gibt hier eine
verbundenheit mit der erde einen sinn
dafür bist du stellst was du hast und
ich kann da immer wieder hin um mich zu
sammeln
ich möchte jetzt nicht hysterisch seien
aber aber es ist wahr wir sind teil
dürfen
das ist unser leben wir sind teil der
erde ohne die erde wären wir ja gar
nicht hier
die kommunen ihr buffalo wurde kürzlich
aufgelöst vom zeitgeist überwuchert und
santa fe bekannt als city different ist
heute in vielerlei hinsicht angepasst
doch die gegenkultur hat überlebt
im industriegebiet der stadt etwa in
besonders experimenteller form
so etwas erwartet man im abgelegenen new
mexico eigentlich nicht
ja es ist ein projekt von 400 künstlern
frei und schräg und extrem erfolgreich
in nur drei jahren wurde dieser ort zum
must für besucher von santa fe
schön schaut ja auch bei uns vorbei es
macht mir viel spaß zu vermitteln was
wir hier tun wir werden immer größer
immer mehr kreative kommen hierher
irgendetwas scheint hier in der luft zu
liegen was die kreativen geistern sind
absolut in los angeles erstickt du im
verkehr
alles ist schwierig und gestresst und
dann kommst du hierher und hast gleich
eine andere lebensqualität fantastische
landschaften kreative leute inspiriert
von der gegend martin hat den mauernden
wölfen auch finanziell auf die beine
geholfen
aus einer alten bowlinghalle wurde so
das haus der ewigen rückkehr
das muss ich euch sagen falls ihr in
unserer multiversum verloren gilt wir
übernehmen keine verantwortung
und damit wir am ende wieder
zurückfinden begleitet uns matt cremans
er ist einer der künstler her
hallo und willkommen in unserem haus
geben sie acht
willkommen im haus der ewigen rückkehr
es ist tatsächlich ein richtiges haus
[Musik]
die idee ist du betrittst ein fremdes
haus in dem immer noch leute gewohnt
haben du kannst schubladen zeitschriften
liegen rom
da und dort ein computer ein kannst du
herumstöbern und so vielleicht etwas
über die geschichte dieses hauses
erfahren
[Musik]
ein bisschen geisterbahn ein bisschen
installation ein bisschen detektivspiel
in der küche finde ich erste spuren der
geschichte die map und seine freunde
hier versteckt habe
jemand starb 2016
wenn jemand von euch hungrig ist sache
der kühlschrank ist leer
[Musik]
ich bin allen schichten ich bin dein
geld und helfe dir heute dein ziel zu
ehrlich sein ziel heißt es bitte begib
dich im raum nummer für nummer vier
[Musik]
ein typ und ich schon immer mal
irgendwas zwischen starcraft und
poltergeist tischlein deck dich
daneben einen schulbus der da aus dem
boden wächst so muss sich eine nsd trip
anfühlen
ich habe einfach nicht finden
[Musik]
siehst du das schwebende kind
was ist mit dem kind passiert
vielleicht von aliens entführt
oder waren es doch geister
[Musik]
das haus gibt eine menge fragen auf
antworten gibt es keine dafür ein pures
fantasy erlebnis das nächste multiversum
entsteht jetzt in las vegas können wir
auch geld verdienen das machen wir die
ganze merchandise hier und so das ist
denke ich auch einer der unterschiede zu
europa wo man als künstlerin im iran
kein kommerz sagt man hier
okay das genau
hier geht irgendwie alles das ist ja
auch das versprechen von mexiko anything
goes
nur die eigenen regeln gelten ein ort
der befreiung geben
[Musik]
ein ort an dem morgen schon alles anders
sein können
auch das wetter für die gewerke muss nur
noch anspringen der gute gott aber
eiskalt ist alles jetzt ist es plötzlich
weiß im südwesten der usa
und wer mit sommerreifen unterwegs gut
geht's heute noch in den süden
hier müssen wir aber unbedingt noch halt
machen blicken jane respektive wegen
jains business sie hat nämlich ein so
richtig zeitloses geschäftsmodell hallo
jungs bist du denn das ist das alu das
hauptgebäude im ort und was würde ich
alles gedreht
was wurde nicht hier gedreht james ryan
stinkt als filmkulisse eigenes
westernstädtchen inklusive den ersten
vier machten wir 1980 parade
das ist das gute am western wie werden
sie den zu klassikern sie haben recht
was schlagen sie vor
schauen wir uns das an ja das können wir
versuchen hier hängen die stars rum
buchstäblich ist jemand drüber
ich habe hier leute von einer firma aus
deutschland sie möchten gerne ein paar
bilder machen
im städtchen mit einer drohne
es wird ein dokumentarfilm und wir
bekommen damit jeder menge werbung
darauf können sie wetten darauf können
sie wetten sagte
durch die bonanza creek oder penélope
cruz heute aber ist es ruhig im ort
gespenstisch ruhig
[Musik]
nur mit einer kamera bewaffnet laufe ich
durch den wilden westen in er froh dass
niemand da ist um mich zum duell
herauszufordern
[Musik]
hier könnte man ewig drehen
doch die straße ruft
[Musik]
spricht sich ihr name so aus mit dem
gebiete kommen sie mir zu meinem wagen
und bringen sie ihre wagen papieren
ja es ist dass sein auto hast du ja habe
ich
[Musik]
ja gesagt weil es so kalt ist können wir
im auto war
das
[Musik]
denkst du fahren wir waren über 100 und
hier ist 75 es ging hat nun raus und die
anderen ja auch so schnell ausgerechnet
uns hat herausgeholt
mit ausbezahlen hier steht der
betrachter
für tierarten wie feed ich gebe da was
draus
es war nur eine verwarnung
es gilt wenn man ausländer ist in den
usa aber etwas wir ziemlich korrekt vor
deswegen sollen es anstellen alle
sollten sich jetzt aus sondern auch
hinten
[Musik]
500 kilometer vom akw entfernt liegt
mexiko palomas heißt das städtchen
tauben hafen
das klingt lieblich ist an einem
novembermorgen um halb sechs aber vor
allem eins nämlich kalt wir drehen einen
dokumentarfilm über die kinder die
kinder die drüben zur schule gehen darum
geht der verbesserten keksen wärmt mich
ein wenig die grenzgänger hier die sind
ein raues klima gewohnt
das von kindesbeinen an morgen für
morgen spielt sich hier die gleiche
szene ab hunderte autos bringen kinder
an die grenze sie leben zwar in mexiko
gehen aber drüben in den usa zur schule
weil sie amerikanische staatsbürger sind
der grenzübergang das ist ihr schulweg
alltag ist das auch für die achtjährige
hannah und ihre mutter lauda kommst du
so früh hier seien sechs uhr manchmal
durchsuchen sie ihre rucksäcke proben
oder waffen solche sachen
dann untersuchten sie alle rucksäcke
alle rucksäcke und das dauert eine weile
dann dauert es länger
bei hunderten kindern alle rucksäcke 30
minuten bis hierher seit dann hier am 6
der bus fährt los geht 45 minuten und
das ist wirklich lange und das jeden tag
jeden tag bist du glücklich dass du in
den usa zu schonen kann
es ist besser wird
der englischunterricht und die lehrer
die schulen hier in mexiko sind teuer
und die schüler kriegen von den lehrern
wenig aufmerksamkeit und ist es heiss im
sommer gibt es keine klimaanlage und im
winter gibt es keine heizung keine reize
wie unterschiedlich das leben doch ist
je nachdem wo man aufwächst
von den chancen die sich nur ein paar
meter weiter im norden auftun können die
meisten andern kids in mexiko nur
träumen ich muss an meine tochter denken
die gleiche art ist wie hemer und an den
schulweg zu hause
am zoll selber durften wir nicht filmen
viel ist auch nicht passiert der
übergang war problemlos rucksack
kontrollen gab es heute keine sind viele
schüler dass er darf den richtigen bus
kommen wirklich gewiss nicht teilen aber
das macht doch viel besser wenn man zu
zweit und meine beste freundin
ok ich will nicht dass er den bus
verpasst danke vielmals hemmer
das hat spaß gemacht denn ist intakt
[Musik]
fliegen müsste man können dann wäre die
grenze nur eine linie in der landschaft
[Musik]
wir fahren weiter richtung osten dieser
linie entlang
gut zu erkennen am meter hohen stahlzaun
der die beiden länder die beiden welten
trend unser ziel ist die gegend in der
new mexiko mexiko und texas
aufeinandertreffen gegenüber von el paso
liegt ciudad juárez wo täglich
flüchtlinge ankommen die von den usa
träumen
damit wir mit diesen menschen auch
sprechen können brauchen wir helfe ich
bin ich schön dich zu sehen noch auf
us-boden in el paso treffen wir die
fotografin monika lozano sie
dokumentiert seit jahren das schicksal
der flüchtlinge in dieser gegend sie
nimmt uns mit nach mexiko nach paris
und du bist hier aufgewachsen ja ich bin
in el paso gewinnerin und in juarez
aufgewachsen alles gleich nebeneinander
alles ganz nach links da haben wir die
universität von texas hier ist wissen
und bildung und da rechts den ärmsten
und gefährlichsten stadtteil von juarez
und die leute von anna brasilien täglich
auf dieses besprechen von einem besseren
leben
aber da ist ein zaun und sie können das
nicht erreichen die bilder von monika
lozano führen in extremer klarheit vor
augen was migranten durchmachen
was flucht bedeutet
[Musik]
nicht interessiert immer warum menschen
auf der flucht sind
dann ist es die schwerste reise die
jemand machen kann sich auf die flucht
zu begeben
im texanischen el paso gehören sie zum
stadtbild männern die sich nach dem
illegalen grenzübertritt als tagelöhner
durchschlagen
sie machen praktisch jede arbeit zu
praktisch jedem lob
hier kommen nun zur grenze und zur
brücke nach wales wir müssen hier was
zahlen
fünf dollar kostet die fahrt über die
brücke monika hat einen grenzgänger
ausweis und darf darum die schnell spur
benutzen
pässe werden nicht verlangt wir
überqueren den programm der zwischen den
usa und mexiko genauso
selbstverständlich wie den rhein
zwischen der schweiz und deutschland
es ist für mich ganz normal über die
grenze zu fahren
ich mache es fast täglich oft bringe ich
meine kinder mit manchmal kaufe ich hier
ein
es ist günstiger und ich mag die
richtigen totti as den käse das gute
essen und jetzt sehen wir die andere
seite des zauns
er hat eine botschaft an migranten aus
dem süden bis hierhin und nicht weiter
menschen auf der flucht betrachten war
es denn auch höchstens als
zwischenstation bevor sie versuchen in
die usa zu kommen verbringen viele von
ihnen ein paar nächte hier in der casa
del migranten monika kommt oft in dieser
notunterkunft um die geschichten der
flucht festzuhalten
das sind freunde journalisten aus der
schweiz
ich bin floris herzlich willkommen seid
ihr einverstanden ein interview zu geben
ja sie wollen mit euch kriegen
woher kommt ihr aus el salvador haben
sie schon versucht in die usa zu kommen
[Musik]
ja sie waren auf der saragossa
grenzbrücke und wurden jetzt hierher
gebracht weil es hier nachts wärmer ist
es ist kalt draußen zwei wochen ist das
her dass diese familie ihre heimat
verlassen musste die beamten gewandt
hatte das leben zur hölle gemacht
sie sagten was jemand tot sei und dass
sie glauben dass heime in das gefährt
wir haben es nicht geglaubt
aber dann ging ich mit meiner familie
durch irland habe gesehen dass es der
vater meiner tochter ist sie haben ihn
die haut vom kopf gerissen
sie haben ihn erwirkt hände und füße
waren gefesselt
die tochter wird schweigend zu während
die mutter den albtraum beschreibt vor
dem die beiden geflohen sind diese
menschen suchen nicht einfach ein
besseres leben in den usa
sie müssen völlig neu anfangen an einem
völlig fremden ort auch die familie aus
guatemala
[Musik]
wir wollen jetzt zur migration büro in
der usa und wenn sie uns die möglichkeit
geben rüber zu gehen ob dann gehen habt
ihr davon gehört dass sie die leute
nicht über die grenze lassen oder dass
die kinder von ihren eltern trennen habt
ihr davon gehört ja davon haben wir
gehört aber wir vertrauen auf gott
beziehungs nicht trennen werden gibt es
auch eine andere möglichkeit
rüberzukommen
darüber haben wir uns noch keine
gedanken
wir wissen dass man auch durch die wüste
gehen kann
aber wir wollen das leben unseres kindes
nicht aufs spiel setzen
wie geht's dir kleine wieder fast nicht
geht es dir hier gut fühlst du dich
sicher und mexiko was denkst du
[Musik]
was fühlst du
die beiden familien haben nun schon mal
ein dach über dem kopf und sie erhalten
informationen über die einreise in die
usa
was die migranten dann tun asyl in den
vereinigten staaten beantragen versuchen
illegal über die grenze zu kommen oder
hier in mexiko bleiben
das ist ihre entscheidung
monika fährt mit uns dorthin wo häufig
menschen versuchen auf die andere seite
zu kommen
die andere seite das zauberland
versprechen der großen freiheit
das bedeutet hier etwas anderes
das ist er dieser zaun zieht sich
bereits über weite strecken des
grenzverlaufs zwischen mexiko und den
usa
nur wenige abschnitte hoffen
entlang des rio grande
wir haben hier eine stelle
da hat ein künstler die metall warnt
blau angemalt um die wand optisch
verschwinden zu lassen
sie wird zu einem teil des himmels auf
der anderen seite findest du immer
wieder schuhe allerlei dinge von leuten
die darüber sind links die usa rechts
mexiko gleiche landschaft ungleiche
länder trüben macht sich die
grenzpolizei bereit ist das eine kamera
die wieder aufbauen
sieht aus wie ein scheinwerfer für die
nacht für die nacht
denkst du der zaun hält die leute davon
ab über die grenze zu gehen
nein ich glaube nicht
wenn man so nah dran steht kann man auch
nachvollziehen dass man dann nicht
umkehrt und sagte okay da ist noch
irgendeine mauer dazwischen
das ist einfach nur noch eines von den
vielen hindernissen dass diese leute
überwinden
ein hindernis ein kunstwerk
eine mauer
was sind grenzen eigentlich
linien in der landschaft letztlich doch
wer die freiheit sucht oder vor
unfreiheit flieht der will nur einer
linie folgen der eigenen
[Musik]
es wird langsam abend und wir müssen
zurück auf die texanische seite
[Musik]
auf dem rückweg darf uns monika mit
ihrem grenzgänger ausweis nicht
mitnehmen als rumreißen wir zu fuß ein
in die usa mit blick auf den rio grande
der schweizer pass macht es uns einfach
so viel einfacher als den familien aus
guatemala und el salvador
[Musik]
bevor mir goodbye sagen wollen wir uns
am getterbach verkaufen
[Musik]
500 mehr bezahlt haben
das ist das discount autos
wenn wir da hin ich heiße auto wie geht
es ihnen gut linie
wir haben das auto vor einer woche in
albuquerque gekauft für eine
fernsehsendung des schweizer fernsehens
wird reden alles dokumentarisch vom kauf
bis zum verkauf ich weiß nicht ich bin
nicht interesse ist nicht interessiert
klassiker ich will dein gesicht
mir gefällt nicht was hier passiert sie
vertrauen und bezahlbare automieter rio
bravo autoverkauf das ist unser gott
ok interesse besteht schon mal machen
wird der jetzt wohl auch keine finden
sie schließlich wie eine eins der motor
doch es bleibt beim beschnüffeln wir
sollen aufhören zu filmen
kein problem ich finde heraus wie er
sagt danke danke dir interessiert
nein auch nicht fährt gut klassisches
design
sie kauften den wagen albuquerque und
wollen jetzt loswerden und die wagen
auch ihre sie haben wie hast du eben
nicht wirklich die originalpapiere haben
wir nicht die wollte uns der verkäufer
nachschicken bis jetzt ist aber nichts
angekommen
die kopie auf dem handy überzeugt hier
nicht
was ist der höchstpreis den werden
ich kaufe kein auto ohne alle wagen
papieren cardillac es dieses auto
abmelden
was tun verschraubten bringen wenn ich
dir das herz
also fahren wir zur einzigen person die
wir in dieser ecke des landes näher
kennen
telefonisch haben wir sie schon mal
vorgewarnt jetzt die wir sind zurück
zurück schön wieder zu sehen
du musst diese man hier ein auto
abkaufen
ich hoffe ich bin vertrauenswürdig genug
was ist passiert
nun wir haben bei mehreren händlern
versucht es zu verkaufen
doch wir konnten beim kauf nicht auf
alle papiere war
sie mussten ja losfahren darum wollte es
uns jetzt kein händler abkaufen
aber es ist ein gutes auto und ihr
stellt es einfach von winehouse ihr seid
verrückt und ich weiß du bist verrückt
genug um es zu kaufen
ja ich kenne tatsächlich mittellose
leute ohne auto dieses autos ja die
dieses auto wirklich gebrauchen kann für
ihr tägliches leben studenten familien
den preis hast du mit bärten
symbolischer preis
adios new mexico
diesmal soll
[Musik]
präsentiert wurden türen wo es noch ein
flug ausfällt
[Musik]